We were going back and forth at Hidden Brain on what to bring you for this final episode of the year, and then it hit us. The turn of the year is a time when we set the old aside and welcome the new into our lives. And so today, we bring you a tale of loss and renewal. It appeals to me for two reasons. The first is it's a very particular and universal story. I was really devastated to lose something that I was completely in love with and so passionate about,
我们在“Hidden Brain”栏目组反复商量，究竟该带给大家这一年最后一期的什么内容，然后我们突然想通了。辞旧迎新之际，正是我们抛下过去、迎来新生活的时刻。因此，今天我们为大家带来一个关于失去与重生的故事。它之所以吸引我，原因有二。首先，这是一个非常特殊却又具有普遍意义的故事。失去我完全热爱、充满激情的事物，我真的备受打击，
and that had really constituted such a large part of my life and my identity. I was first and foremost a violinist. The second reason is that this is also about social science research and its applications in the real world. What we found was a 9% increase in college enrollment rates. As a result of 8 text messages. I mean that is really profound.
而那曾构成我生活和身份中如此巨大的一部分。我首先是一名小提琴手。第二个原因则是，这也关乎社会科学研究及其在现实世界中的应用。我们发现，大学入学率提高了9%。仅仅因为8条短信。我的意思是，这真的是深远的影响。
8 text messages is what I send my best friend on any given day. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vidanthan. Today we're telling you a story that begins in the attic of a home in Connecticut and ends at the White House. And on our theme of loss and reinvention, we'll bring you a poem I came across from Elizabeth Bishop, read by musician Amy Mann. Then practice losing farther, losing faster, places and names and where it was you meant to travel. None of these will bring disaster.
发8条短信正是我平时发给我最好的朋友的数量。这里是“Hidden Brain”，我是香卡·维丹坦（Shankar Vedantam）。今天我们要给大家讲述一个故事，它始于康涅狄格州一所房子的阁楼，终于白宫。围绕着失去与重塑这一主题，我们将为您朗诵一首我偶然读到的伊丽莎白·毕晓普（Elizabeth Bishop）的诗，由音乐家艾米·曼恩（Amy Mann）朗读。然后练习失去得更远，失去得更快，地方、名字以及你原本打算去旅行的地方。这些都不会带来灾难。
My grandmother was an Indian classical violinist and so my mom had her old violin and aratic for many years. This is Maya Shankar, no relation. Each of my three older siblings had rejected the violin saying that it wasn't cool enough and my mom finally gave me the instrument and I was immediately taken kind of by the tactile sensation of the instrument. I mean the wood and the bow. I just loved the feeling of playing the violin. Even as a child Maya immediately loved everything about the violin. The way it looked, the way it felt, the way it sounded. Maya's mother didn't know much about western classical music, but she signed up her daughter for lessons using the Suzuki method. The focus was on playing by ear and making beautiful sound.
我的祖母是一位印度古典小提琴手，所以我妈妈多年来一直在阁楼里保留着她的旧小提琴。我是玛雅·尚卡尔（Maya Shankar），没有亲戚关系。我的三个哥哥姐姐都曾拒绝过这把小提琴，说它不够酷，我妈妈最终把这把乐器给了我，我立刻就被这把乐器的触感所吸引了。我是说木头和琴弓。我就是喜欢拉小提琴的感觉。即使在还是个孩子的时候，玛雅就立刻喜欢上了关于小提琴的一切。它的外观，它的手感，它的声音。玛雅的母亲对西方古典音乐并不太了解，但她用铃木教学法（Suzuki method）为女儿报了名。重点是凭耳听来演奏并发出美妙的声音。
Maya practiced constantly. I had a special scheduled school to lump all my classes together so that I come a little bit early and get a little bit more practice in, and especially with all the traveling, most days were devoted exclusively to music. She got good, very good. Now the part of her musical education that was missing was the formal part. She didn't know how to read music very well, but she had a fine ear and she had ambition. In the pursuit to find a teacher who would take her to the next level, Maya's mother did
玛雅不断地练习。我有一个特殊的学校日程安排，把所有的课程集中在一起，这样我可以早点去，多练习一会儿，尤其是伴随着各种奔波，大多数日子都是全心投入在音乐上。她进步很快，非常快。现在，她唯一的音乐教育中所缺少的是正规的部分。她不太会识谱，但她有着敏锐的耳朵和远大的抱负。为了寻找能带她走向更高水平的老师，玛雅的母亲做出了
something quite daring. Yeah, so my mom, she was really a go-getter when it came to my violin life because, like I said, she didn't really have a lot of Experiencer exposure to the music community and kind of had to innovate in order to find opportunities There were a New York one day close to the Julia at school one of the world's most famous and exclusive music institutions When her mother came up with an idea. She said why don't we just go to Julia? I mean why not right what can we just go to Juilliard? I mean, why not? Right? What can we lose? Just walk in the door.
一件相当大胆的事。是的，所以对于我的小提琴生涯，我妈妈真的是个很有冲劲的人，因为正如我所说，她其实并没有太多音乐界的经验或接触，为了寻找机会不得不有所创新。有一天他们在纽约，靠近朱莉亚音乐学院（Juilliard School）——世界上最著名且最独一无二的音乐机构之一。当时她的母亲产生了一个想法。她说，我们为什么不去朱莉亚呢？我的意思是，为什么不呢？对吧？我们能去朱莉亚音乐学院吗？我的意思是，为什么不呢？对吧？我们有什么好失去的？直接走进去。
We just walked in. So we walked into the building and just by happenstance, we happened to run into a student in the elevator who studied with a music teacher and my mom talked to that family and the elevator and said, would you mind if we just had about five or 10 minutes at the end of your lesson where Maya could play for your teacher? And they were really gracious and they said, sure, no problem.
我们就这样走进去了。于是我们走进了那栋大楼，机缘巧合之下，我们在电梯里碰巧遇到了一位学生，他跟着一位音乐老师学习，我妈妈在电梯里和那个家庭交谈，并说，你们介不介意在你们课程结束时留出大约五到十分钟的时间，让玛雅为你们的老师演奏一次？他们非常慷慨，并说，当然，没问题。
Of course, you know what happened next. Maya played for the other students' music teacher, wilded the teacher, and got accepted into a summer program. Soon she was taking classes at Juilliard. She was playing with other talented musicians. She was even being featured on NPR. Joining us now is the Juliet pre-college violin quartet. They are 17-year-old Emily Gendron from Glassdenberry Connecticut. 15-year-old Maya Shankar from Cheshire, Connecticut. Maya, by the way, is a from-the-top veteran.
当然，你知道接下来发生了什么。玛雅为那位其他学生的音乐老师演奏了，惊艳了老师，并被一个暑期项目录取了。不久后，她就在朱莉亚学院上课了。她和其他才华横溢的音乐家一起演奏。她甚至还登上了美国国家公共广播电台（NPR）。现在加入我们的是朱莉亚预科小提琴四重奏。他们是来自康涅狄格州格拉斯登伯里的17岁女孩艾米丽·根德龙（Emily Gendron）。来自康涅狄格州柴郡的15岁女孩玛雅·尚卡尔（Maya Shankar）。顺便说一句，玛雅是“From the Top”节目的老将。
She's been with us since the early 50s. That was Maya on NPR's From the Top. She had found her classical music home. She was talented, hardworking, and the path before her seemed clear. I really wanted to be a violinist. I was so passionate about it. I never felt more comfortable than when I was performing. For some reason, that's where I experienced flow. And the ability to spend a lot of time practicing
她从50年代初就一直和我们在一起。那是玛雅在NPR的《From the Top》节目中的表现。她找到了她的古典音乐归宿。她很有天赋，工作努力，她面前的道路似乎很清晰。我真的很想成为一名小提琴手。我对此充满了热情。当我表演时，我从未感到如此自在。出于某种原因，正是在那里我体验到了心流。以及花大量时间练习的能力，
and trying to perfect the art, and then you go on stage and you kind of just surrender. And you play to the best of your abilities. There's just something beautiful and elegant about that process. And I just really really really loved it. She was so good and so enthusiastic that opportunities kept presenting themselves. One day her teacher at Juliet arranged for her to play for a famous violinist, a very famous violinist.
并试图完善这种艺术，然后你走上舞台，有点像是全情投入。并发挥出你的最佳水平。这个过程有一种美丽而优雅的东西。我真的非常非常喜欢它。她太优秀、太有热情了，以至于机会不断向她涌来。有一天，她在朱莉亚的老师安排她为一位著名的小提琴手演奏，一位非常著名的小提琴手。
I nearly fell over in my seat because no reasonable musician thinks they're going to get the opportunity to meet its octoprolemen, let alone play for its octoprolemen. Do you remember what you played? I played the Barber Violin Contrary, I played the first movement. The PURLMAN decided to take her on as a student. In addition to Saturdays, I was also going to New York multiple times during the week, either for studio classes at his home in Manhattan or for private lessons or chamber music lessons, and at that point it was very clear to me that I wanted to become a concert violinist. Well I remember that she sounded, she had a very lovely, we're making music, and that's
我差点从座位上摔下来，因为没有哪个理智的音乐家会认为自己有机会见到伊扎克·帕尔曼（Itzak Perlman），更不用说为他演奏了。你还记得你当时拉的是什么吗？我演奏了巴伯小提琴协奏曲（Barber Violin Concerto），我拉了第一乐章。帕尔曼决定收她为学生。除了星期六，我每周还要去纽约好几次，要么去他在曼哈顿家中的工作室上课，要么去上私教课或室内乐课，当时我很清楚，我想成为一名音乐会小提琴手。嗯，我记得她的声音很好听，我们在做音乐，而对我来说
for me a resource the most important thing. To concert violinist Itzak Pearlman, it was okay that Maya had learned to play music by ear rather than by reading music. The technical stuff was important, but it could be learned. You know, it's more important for me to have somebody musical. And let's say that the technique wise has, you know, you have to work on the technique, but the important thing is the music. And I felt that you had a very lovely way of phrasing and so on and so forth.
音乐资源是最重要的事。对于音乐会小提琴手伊扎克·帕尔曼来说，玛雅是通过听力而不是通过识谱来学习音乐并没有关系。技术性的东西很重要，但它是可以学习的。你知道，对我来说，找一个有音乐感的人更重要。比方说，技巧方面，你知道的，你必须在技巧上下功夫，但重要的是音乐。我觉得你有一种非常可爱的乐句处理方式，诸如此类。
And so we worked on that, but then we also worked on, you know, how do you accomplish, technically, certain things. For example, in the Barbara concert, a little lost movement is a little bit tricky. So how do you practice that? But Perlman didn't just teach Maya how to play the violin. He taught her something much more important. How to teach how to play the violin, he taught her something much more important. How to teach herself to play the violin. I remember lots of lessons were, instead of telling me, Maya, okay, clearly you're unsatisfied with that phrase.
所以我们在这方面下了功夫，但我们也研究了，你知道的，如何在技术上实现某些事情。例如，在巴伯协奏曲中，末乐章有点棘手。那么你该如何练习呢？但帕尔曼不仅教玛雅如何拉小提琴。他教会了她更重要的事。如何教自己拉小提琴，他教会了她更重要的事。如何教自己拉小提琴。我记得有很多次课，帕尔曼没有直接告诉我：“玛雅，好吧，显然你对那个乐句不满意。
Here's what you should do to make it better. He would instead say, Maya, clearly you're unsatisfied with that phrase, what do you think you should do in order to make that phrase better? Let's talk about it. Let me hear what your aspirations are for the arc of this musical phrase. What tools do you have at your disposal, either with your bow arm or your vibrato or your tone in order to make it beautiful? And it's really frustrating. I mean, in the moment you're thinking, okay, man, like you're the expert here, you know. Just tell me what to do. Please just tell me what to do and make this easier for both of us.
这是你应该做的，以使它变得更好。”而是会说：“玛雅，很明显你对那个乐句不满意，你觉得为了让那个乐句变得更好，你应该怎么做？我们来谈谈吧。让我听听你对这个音乐乐句走向的期望是什么。你有哪些现成的工具，无论是你的琴弓手臂、你的揉弦（vibrato）还是你的音色，来让它变得优美？”这真的很让人沮丧。我的意思是，那一刻你在想，好吧，老兄，你才是这里的专家，你知道的。直接告诉我该怎么做。求你了，直接告诉我该怎么做，让我们俩都轻松点。
So the more you learn, the more to think for yourself and to try and solve problems on your own, the better it is for you for the future. It was all going so well. When Maya was 15, she was practicing at a program run by its sock parliament. And I was playing a passage from a very challenging Paganini Caprice. And I simply overstretched my finger on one note, and I felt kind of a popping. And so I overstretched the tendon, and it didn't really heal as expected. And so how did you spend the next months? What did you do? Well, Mr. Prolman was such a gem because I injured my left hand. He continued to teach me violin
所以你学到的越多，越是为自己思考并尝试自己解决问题，对你的未来就越好。一切都进展得如此顺利。玛雅15岁时，在一个由伊扎克·帕尔曼举办的项目中练习。当时我正在演奏帕格尼尼随想曲（Paganini Caprice）中一个非常具有挑战性的乐段。我只是在一个音符上过度伸展了我的手指，然后我感觉到了一种轻微的“啪”的声音。于是我拉伤了肌腱，它并没有像预期那样愈合。那么你是怎么度过接下来的几个月的呢？你做了什么？嗯，帕尔曼先生真是个活宝，因为我的左手受伤了。他继续教我拉小提琴，
just with my bow arm. So for over a year, I went to him and we just worked on perfecting my bow arm and I would just play open strings in every lesson. And he would teach me about how to produce a beautiful sound. You know, you always feel that, you know, it will resolve itself, so usually what happens if one hand doesn't particularly, you know, respond or anything like this, you work on the other hand just, you know, not to waste time just to do so if you've got your left hand that has a problem, then you work on the right hand and vice versa.
只是用我的琴弓手臂。所以在一年多的时间里，我去找他，我们只是致力于完善我的琴弓手臂，我在每一节课上都只拉空弦。他教我如何发出美妙的声音。你知道，你总会觉得，这会自己好起来的，所以通常发生的情况是，如果一只手特别没有反应或者发生类似的事情，你就去练习另一手，你知道的，不要浪费时间，只要这样做就好。如果你左手有问题，那么你就练习右手，反之亦然。
It's good, you know, her attitude was, you know, I mean, obviously she wasn't, I mean, I'm sure that she was feeling good about it, but it was never like what's to use. Maya's hand didn't heal. Doctors finally told her she had to stop playing completely. I was really devastated to lose something that I was completely in love with and so passionate about, and that had really constituted such a large part of my life and my identity. You know, I was first and foremost a violinist. And so I was anxious because I was worried that I would never find something that I felt as passionately about as I did with music.
这很好，你知道的，她的态度是，你知道的，我的意思是，显然她并不是，我的意思是，我确信她对此感觉很好，但从来没有那种“有什么用”的感觉。玛雅的手没有痊愈。医生最终告诉她，她必须完全停止演奏。失去我完全热爱、充满激情的事物，我真的备受打击，而那曾构成我生活和身份中如此巨大的一部分。你知道的，我首先是一名小提琴手。因此我很焦虑，因为我担心我再也找不到让我像对音乐那样充满热情的事物了。
Just like that, Maya's dream to become a concert violinist was over. Back home for the summer in Connecticut, she started to ask herself how she could pick up the pieces, would she ever find anything that could make her as happy as the violin? Our next guest appeared as a violinist on a pilot episode when she was just 12 years old. She's now 23 and during those intervening years, well, brace yourself because what she's accomplished is a little humbling to us mere mortals.
就这样，玛雅成为音乐会小提琴手的梦想破灭了。夏天回到康涅狄格州的家中，她开始问自己该如何收拾残局，她还能找到能让她像小提琴一样快乐的事物吗？我们的下一位嘉宾在12岁时曾作为小提琴手出现在试播集中。她现在23岁了，在那些年间，嗯，做好心理准备吧，因为她所取得的成就让我们这些凡人感到有点自惭形秽。
Please welcome Maya Shankar. To find out what Maya did, stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanthan. On our last podcast of the year, we're exploring the idea of closing the book on one chapter of your life and opening another. We're doing it through the idea of closing the book on one chapter of your life and opening another. We're doing it through the story of Maya Shankar. After learning she could no longer play the violin due to an injury to her left hand, Maya retreated to her parents' home in Connecticut. Her life felt indiscery. The summer before doctors basically told me I'd just stop playing
有请玛雅·尚卡尔（Maya Shankar）。想知道玛雅做了什么，请继续收听我们节目。这里是“Hidden Brain”，我是香卡·维丹坦（Shankar Vedantan）。在我们今年的最后一期播客中，我们正在探讨合上你生命中的一个章节并开启另一个章节的想法。我们正通过玛雅·尚卡尔的故事来探讨这个想法。在得知由于左手受伤而再也无法拉小提琴后，玛雅退回了父母在康涅狄格州的家中。她的生活感到一片迷茫。就在医生基本上告诉我必须完全停止演奏前的那个夏天，
completely, and just by luck I was helping my parents clean their basement in Cheshire, Connecticut, and I stumbled upon an old course book of my sisters. It was called The Language Instinct by Stephen Pinker. My ass started reading, and the more she read, the more excited she became. It was remarkable for me to learn about just how complex our minds were, and just what was required in order for us to have our day-to-day experiences. And so, it really went my appetite for learning more about the mind and for exploring and more depth, kind of the brilliance of the brain.
纯粹出于运气，我正在帮父母清理他们在康涅狄格州柴郡的地下室，我偶然发现了姐姐的一本旧教科书。书名叫史蒂芬·平克（Steven Pinker）的《语言本能》（The Language Instinct）。玛雅开始阅读，她读得越多，就越兴奋。了解我们的心灵是多么复杂，以及为了拥有日常体验到底需要什么，这对我来说是非同寻常的。因此，它确实唤起了我进一步了解大脑以及更深入地探索大脑之美的好奇心。
She started to study cognitive science. She went on to get her PhD at Oxford on a Rhodes scholarship. She got a postdoctoral fellowship, a promising career in academia lay ahead of her. But here again, came another unexpected turn. So over Thanksgiving break of the final year of my postdoc, I was at home and I was visiting my undergraduate advisor from college, named Laurie Santos. And she was telling me about the U.S. Department of Agriculture's efforts to get free and reduce price lunches, school lunches, into the hands of more eligible students.
她开始学习认知科学。她凭借罗德奖学金（Rhodes scholarship）前往牛津大学攻读博士学位。她获得了博士后研究奖学金，学术界的前途一片光明。但在这里，又迎来了另一个意料之外的转折。所以，在我博士后最后一年感恩节假期的时候，我在家里拜访了我在大学时的本科导师，名叫劳瑞·桑托斯（Laurie Santos）。她当时正跟我讲美国农业部（U.S. Department of Agriculture）为将免费和减价午餐——学校午餐——送到更多符合条件的学生的努力。
Students were going hungry because the process of getting certified for the lunch program was cumbersome. The Department of Agriculture came up with a simple idea. Instead of having a multi-step sign-up system, states could use information they already had about poor families to help enroll children in the lunch program. And it's just a matter of data matching and cross-enrolling these students. But as a result of this common sense reform, you know, 12.4 million students, as of 2015, were automatically enrolled into the school lunch program and had access to lunches and
学生们挨饿是因为申请午餐计划的认证过程繁琐不堪。农业部想出一个简单的想法。各州不用再建立多步骤的注册系统，而是可以利用它们已经掌握的关于贫困家庭的信息，来帮助儿童注册午餐计划。这只是一个数据匹配和让这些学生交叉注册的问题。但由于这项常识性的改革，你知道的，截至2015年，有1240万学生被自动纳入学校午餐计划，获得了午餐，并且
were able to thrive at school. And I remember being so moved by this example. Tomaya, it was magical. It was just like a light bulb went off in my head and I thought, okay, this is what I need to be doing with my life. I want to be taking research insights from the behavioral sciences and allowing them to find their way into public policy so that they can be in the service of Americans and people around the world. So how do you break into the world of policy when you're just a lowly postdoc? Mayan knew nothing of politics. She didn't have connections in the world of government.
能够在学校茁壮成长。我记得我被这个例子深深感动了。对玛雅来说，这简直太神奇了。就像脑子里亮起了一盏灯，我想，好吧，这就是我这一生应该做的事。我想把来自行为科学的研究见解应用到公共政策中，让它们服务于美国人以及世界各地的人们。那么，当你只是一个低微的博士后时，你是如何闯入政策世界的呢？玛雅对政治一无所知。她在政府世界里没有任何人脉。
But she did remember a lesson her mother had taught her Standing outside the Julliard school years earlier She tracked down an email address for Thomas Kalea who was helping the Obama administration with its science policy I sent Tom again a cold email This is the Julliard method again. This is my mom's Julliard. I get to give her full credit for this She is totally fearless and kind of inspired this trait. And I went over to his home and he asked me to pitch to him ideas that I had around interventions where behavioral science could improve public policy outcomes.
但她确实记得母亲多年前在朱莉亚音乐学院门外教给她的那一课。她找到了托马斯·卡勒（Thomas Kalea）的电子邮箱地址，他当时正在协助奥巴马政府制定科学政策。我给托姆发了一封冷邮件。这又是朱莉亚的方法。这是我妈妈的朱莉亚方法。我得把全部功劳归功于她。她完全无所畏惧，某种程度上启发了这种特质。我去了他家，他让我向他推销我关于行为科学可以改善公共政策结果的干预措施的想法。
What did you tell him? I talked to him about a number of things like the importance of using social norms to motivate behavior. So we know from research that if you tell people that their neighbors use less energy than they do, right, they're more likely to use less energy. And there's a lot of domains in which just telling people what the data shows about people's actions and decisions can actually drive actions that are more in alignment with people's long-term goals or with policy objectives. Something that struck me about that conversation is I had been talking for years with my academic colleagues about the potential applications of using behavioral insights
你跟他说什么了？我和他谈了很多事情，比如利用社会规范来激励行为的重要性。所以我们从研究中知道，如果你告诉人们他们的邻居比他们消耗更少的能量，对吧，他们就更有可能消耗更少的能量。在很多领域，仅仅告诉人们关于人们行动和决定的数据是什么，实际上就可以推动更加符合人们长期目标或政策目标的行动。那次对话中有一件事让我印象深刻，多年来我一直与我的学术同仁们讨论将行为洞察力应用于
to improve people's lives. This was the first time that when I told him an idea that I had, his response was, oh, we can find a way to do that. Maya joined the White House. She was asked to put together a team that could marshal ideas from social science research and apply them to public policy challenges. You've had a chance in your current role to actually work on this project that started you on this mission, the school lunch program. Can you tell me a little bit about that? So we have been working with the U.S. Department of Agriculture and also local school districts
改善人们生活的潜在应用。这是我第一次向他讲述我的一个想法时，他的回应是：“哦，我们可以找到办法做到这一点。”玛雅加入了白宫。她被要求组建一个团队，将社会科学研究的理念整理并应用到公共政策的挑战中。在你目前的职位上，你确实有机会参与这个让你踏上这项使命的项目——学校午餐计划。你能跟我讲讲那个项目吗？所以我们一直在与美国农业部以及地方学区合作，
to redesign communications that they're sending to families to help promote the verification process so that their kids can stay on the benefit. So we've done a few things. So there's a few behavioral insights that we've used. One is we've taken a very long list of, you know, action steps required for verification and condense them into three easy and understand steps that you can take. Two, we've worked with school districts to translate the communications into multiple languages in order to support comprehension among the diverse population that this program serves.
重新设计他们发送给家庭的信件，以帮助推动核实流程，从而使他们的孩子能够继续享受福利。所以我们做了一些事情。所以我们使用了一些行为洞察。第一，我们将一份长长的、你知道的，核实所需的行动步骤清单，浓缩成了三个你可以采取的简单易懂的步骤。第二，我们与学区合作，将信件翻译成多种语言，以支持这个项目服务的多元化人群的理解。
One issue is that at present, families might only think the way to recertify or to verify their information is to send snail mail back to the school district. And instead, there's the opportunity for them to take a picture of their information using their mobile phones and actually email it back. And we simply notified people of the opportunity to go through that process. And then in other instances we included prepaid envelopes to help ease the process of verifying eligibility. So I'm trying to think about why it is we often have trouble sort of thinking about programs like this because as someone who has been interested in human behavior for a while It seems to me that programs like these really are you know, no pun intended a no-brainer that this is really something that we should be doing
一个问题是，目前，家庭可能认为重新认证或核实其信息的唯一方法是将平信寄回学区。相反，他们有机会使用手机拍摄其信息的照片，并实际将其通过电子邮件发回。我们只是通知人们可以通过这个流程的机会。然后在其他情况下，我们附上了预付费信封，以帮助简化核实资格的过程。所以我在思考，为什么我们经常难以思考像这样的项目，因为作为一个关注人类行为一段时间的人来说，
It seems obvious that we should be doing it But but I think part of the issue is that I think many people might say if you want to stay in a program that's giving you benefits And these are the steps you need to do in order to get the benefits and you deserve those benefits rationally speaking you should be willing to do those steps in order to get the benefits and I think it fails to take into account The difference between how human beings are supposed to behave as rational creatures and how they actually behave and I feel like that's the Central divide that your work is trying to bridge. And I think additionally, you know, the onus is on the government to present information clearly, to present choices clearly, so that people understand what program exists and
在我看来，像这样的项目真的——双关语意，不言而喻——这确实是我们应该做的事情。这似乎显而易见，我们应该这样做，但但我想部分问题在于，我认为许多人可能会说，如果你想留在给你提供福利的项目中，而这些是你为了获得福利需要做的步骤，而且你应得这些福利，从理性上讲，你应该愿意做这些步骤来获得福利，而我认为这没有考虑到人类作为理性生物本该如何行为与他们实际如何行为之间的差异，我觉得这是你的工作试图弥合的核心分歧。而且我认为此外，你知道的，政府有责任清晰地呈现信息，清晰地呈现选择，以便人们了解存在什么项目，
what their options are and can make the best decisions for themselves and their families. But there's one example that I wanted to point to, which is a phenomenon known as summer melt. This is the phenomenon where talented high school students who are on track to go to college at the start of the summer somehow lose their way and don't show up at college in the fall. Maya and her team have worked on simple, low-cost interventions that can help these students get to college. Their idea, send the students eight text messages over the summer, reminding them of impending deadlines.
他们的选择是什么，并为自己和家人做出最佳决策。但我想要指出的一个例子是，一个被称为“暑期消融”（summer melt）的现象。这是一个这样的现象：那些在暑假开始时本来很有希望上大学的高中优等生，在夏天不知怎么就迷失了方向，到了秋天却没有去上大学。玛雅和她的团队致力于研究简单的、低成本的干预措施，以帮助这些学生上大学。他们的想法是，在夏天给学生发送八条短信，提醒他们即将到来的截止日期。
What we found was a 9% increase in college enrollment rates. As a result of eight text messages, I mean that is really profound. Eight text messages is what I send my best friend on any given day. It seems to me that what you did and what happened to you is actually happens to lots of people all the time where doors close and they feel like it's unbearable that this door is closed because this is where I thought I lived, and then another door opens and you realize there are actually many, many houses in which we can live.
我们发现，大学入学率提高了9%。仅仅因为8条短信。我的意思是，这真的是深远的影响。发8条短信正是我平时发给我最好的朋友的数量。在我看来，你所做的事以及发生在你身上的事，实际上一直在许多人身上发生：大门关闭了，他们觉得这扇门关了简直令人无法忍受，因为这就是我以为我生活的地方，然后另一扇门打开了，你意识到实际上有许许多多我们可以居住的房子。
I think that's exactly right. And I think one thing that violin, one of the great blessings of playing the violin is that it allowed me to see what it really felt like to be in love with something and to be really passionate about something. And so if anything, you see sort of features or traits that are extracted in you from engaging with that pursuit.
我想完全正确。而且我认为小提琴的一点，拉小提琴的一大幸事在于，它让我看到真正爱上一件事并对一件事充满热情是什么感觉。所以如果说有什么的话，你会看到那些通过参与那种追求而在你身上激发出来的特征或特质。
And then your hope is that in the new explorations, those disciplines or those areas can extract those same qualities from you. I'm wondering as you think about your own life, do you feel that your career now has been set this is the house you're going to live in forever do you actually believe on the other hand that they might be many other houses you will one day come to live in? Well certainly never been happier than I am right now working in public service and using my background to help
然后你的希望是，在新的探索中，那些学科或那些领域能够从你身上激发出相同的品质。我想知道，当你思考你自己的生活时，你是否觉得你的事业已经定型了，这就是你将永远居住的房子？另一方面，你是否真的相信可能会有许多其他你有一天会去居住的房子？嗯，当然，从事公共服务并用我的背景来帮助
improve people's lives so I think that that will continue to be a common theme of whatever it is that I end up doing and working in that So I think that that will continue to be a common theme of whatever it is that I end up doing and working in. That said, I think there are so many ways in which that passion can manifest, right? And I think that one thing the past has taught me is that the world has endless opportunities to positively impact people's lives. And along the way, I might explore various different paths in order to get there. But as long as I stick to that core value of trying to help people and improve people's lives,
改善人们的生活，我从来没有像现在这样快乐过，所以我认为这将继续是我最终所做和所从事的任何事情的共同主题。话虽如此，我认为这种热情可以通过多种方式表现出来，对吧？而且我认为过去教给我的一件事是，世界有无数的机会对人们的生活产生积极的影响。在这个过程中，为了到达那里，我可能会探索各种不同的道路。但只要我坚持试图帮助人们和改善人们生活这一核心价值观，
I think that there are many ways to do that. And of course, you have the cold-call Julia method to aid you. Yeah. So I think that, again, thanks to my mom, I think that there is always that full proof method of the standard coal-call. That was Maya Shankar.
我认为有许多方法可以做到这一点。当然，你还有冷邮件朱莉亚方法来帮助你。是的。所以我想，再次感谢我妈妈，我认为标准冷邮件这种万无一失的方法永远存在。那是玛雅·尚卡尔。
She served as senior advisor for the social and behavioral sciences at the White House Office of Science and Technology Policy on the President Obama. Since then, Maya has left the White House and become Google's first head of behavioral insights. I told you at the start of this episode that Maya's story is a universal story. Now not all of us are going to be concert via Linus or Rhodes Scholars or Presidential Advisors, but I don't think any of those things are the real point of Maya's story. The reason I wanted to tell you the story at at the turn of a new year, is because all of
她曾在奥巴马总统任内的白宫科学与技术政策办公室（Office of Science and Technology Policy）担任社会与行为科学高级顾问。从那以后，玛雅离开白宫，成为了谷歌的第一任行为洞察主管。我在本集节目开始时告诉你，玛雅的故事是一个具有普遍意义的故事。现在，我们并非所有人都会成为音乐会小提琴手、罗德学者或总统顾问，但我不认为其中任何一件事是玛雅故事的真正重点。我想在新年到来之际给你讲这个故事的原因是，我们所有
us have chapters in our lives that close. And when they do, especially if it's a chapter we have known and loved for a long time, it can feel like the whole book is over, that there's nothing left to do, maybe even nothing left to live for. But I think each of us has stories in our lives that reflect the fact that the people we are today are not the same people we were a few years ago. We often underestimate our capacity to reinvent ourselves. I was talking some years ago with Rick Pots.
人的生活都有画上句号的章节。当它们结束时，特别是如果这是一个我们相知并热爱了很久的章节，感觉就像整本书都结束了，好像什么都没剩下可做的了，甚至可能连活下去的理由都没了。但我认为我们每个人的生活中都有这样的故事，它们反映出我们今天的自己与几年前的自己已经判若两人。我们常常低估了自己重塑自我的能力。几年前我曾与里克·波茨（Rick Potts）交谈过。
He's a paleoanthropologist and the head of the Smithsonian Institution's Human Origins program. And something he said stuck in my head. He told me that the thing that distinguished early humans from other species was our remarkable capacity to adapt to different conditions, different situations. Uniquely, humans live in very cold places and very hot places, at altitude and sea level, some of us live long periods underwater or even in outer space. Most of that isn't about our physical abilities, it's really about the mind.
他是一位古人类学家，也是史密森尼学会（Smithsonian Institution）人类起源项目的负责人。他所说的一句话留在了我的脑海里。他告诉我，早期人类与其他物种的区别在于我们非凡的适应不同环境、不同情境的能力。独特的是，人类生活在非常寒冷的地方和非常炎热的地方、高海拔和海平面，我们中的一些人在水下甚至太空中生活很长时间。这大部分不关乎我们的身体能力，它实际上关乎大脑。
And each year, around this time, we need to remind ourselves that as one door closes, we have the ability to find other doors to open. I want to leave you with a lovely poem by Elizabeth Bishop. Singer Amy Mann happened to be at NPR and we asked her to read the poem for us. One art by Elizabeth Bishop. The art of losing isn't hard to master. So many things seem filled with the intent to be lost, that their loss is no disaster. Lose something every day, except the fluster of lost dorkies, the hour badly spent, the
每年这个时候，我们都需要提醒自己，当一扇门关闭时，我们有能力找到其他开启的门。我想以伊丽莎白·毕晓普的一首可爱的诗作为结束。歌手艾米·曼恩恰好在NPR，我们请她为我们朗诵了这首诗。伊丽莎白·毕晓普的《一种艺术》（One Art）。失落的艺术并不难掌握。许多事情似乎都充满了被遗失的意图，以至于它们的遗失并非灾难。每天失去一些东西，除了弄丢钥匙的慌乱，虚度光阴的懊恼，
art of losing isn't hard to master. Then practice losing farther, losing faster, places and names and where it was you meant to travel. None of these will bring disaster. I lost my mother's watch. And look, my last or next to last of three loved houses went. The art of losing isn't hard to master. I lost two cities' lovely ones, and Vaster, some realms I owned, two rivers a continent, I missed them but
失落的艺术并不难掌握。然后练习失去得更远，失去得更快，地方、名字以及你原本打算去旅行的地方。这些都不会带来灾难。我弄丢了我母亲的手表。看吧，我三座挚爱的房子中的最后一座或倒数第二座也失去了。失落的艺术并不难掌握。我失去了两座可爱的城市，以及更广阔的、我曾拥有的一些王国，两条河流，一个大洲，我想念它们，但
it wasn't a disaster. Even losing you, the joking voice suggests your I love. I shant have lied. It's evident the art of losing is not too hard to master, though it may look like, write it, like disaster. That was Amy Mann, reading one art by Elizabeth Bishop. Amy was at NPR with Ted Leo to perform for the All Songs Considerate podcast. This episode was produced by Maggie Pennman and Kara McGurk Allison. Our team includes Jenny Schmidt, Parth Shah, Reyna Cohen, Laura Corarelle, Tara Boyle, Thomas Liu, and Camila Vargas Trestrapo.
这并非灾难。甚至失去你，这开玩笑的声音暗示着你的“我爱你”，我并未撒谎。显而易见，失落的艺术并不算太难掌握，尽管它可能看起来，写下来，就像一场灾难。那是艾米·曼恩，朗诵伊丽莎白·毕晓普的《一种艺术》。艾米当时和泰德·莱奥（Ted Leo）一起在NPR为“All Songs Considered”播客表演。本集节目由玛吉·佩恩曼（Maggie Pennman）和卡拉·麦格克·艾森（Kara McGurk Allison）制作。我们的团队包括珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmidt）、帕尔斯·沙阿（Parth Shah）、雷娜·科恩（Reyna Cohen）、劳拉·科拉雷莱（Laura Corarelle）、塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）、托马斯·刘（Thomas Liu）以及卡米拉·巴尔加斯·特雷斯特拉波（Camila Vargas Trestrapo）。
Our unsung hero this week is someone who helped me reinvent my own life. Paul Ginsburg is a longtime NPR supporter and donor. In December 2013, Paul came to me and told me I should be doing more than just weekly stories for radio. What about a podcast he asked? Paul did more than just simply toss out an idea. He helped to make it a reality. He raised funds to launch Hidden Brain and he's been a trusted friend and advisor ever since. More than time and money, Paul gave me what might be the most valuable gift one person can give another. He helped me see something in myself that I had not seen on my own.
我们本周的无名英雄是一位帮助我重塑自己生活的人。保罗·金斯伯格（Paul Ginsburg）是NPR的长期支持者和捐赠者。2013年12月，保罗找到我，告诉我我不应该只为电台做每周的故事。播客怎么样？他问道。保罗不仅仅是抛出一个想法。他协助将其变成了现实。他为启动“Hidden Brain”筹集了资金，从那以后他一直是我值得信赖的朋友和顾问。比起时间和金钱，保罗给予我可能是一个人能给另一个人的最宝贵的礼物。他帮我在自己身上看到了一种我从未独自发现的东西。
Thanks Paul. From everyone at Hidden Brain, we wish you new paths, new dreams, and much reinvention this coming year. I'm Shankar Vedantam, and this is NPR. this coming year. I'm Shankar Vedantam and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢你，保罗。来自“Hidden Brain”的全体成员，我们祝愿你在新的一年里拥有新的道路、新的梦想以及无限的重塑。我是香卡·维丹坦，这里是NPR。在新的一年里。我是香卡·维丹坦，这里是NPR。本集节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。